hello reject nation Craig Alva here and
John Humphrey over here we're gonna
watch today the Deadpool wet-on-wet
teaser trailer oh boy that's terminology
I know yes there I think from the
thumbnail looks like it's a parody of
yeah hatred in the day shout I'm gonna
go out to Andrew Terpening today my
friends Smith all right well let's let's
check this out who shot it afterwards
mr. patron
[Music]
this is your world
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
making friends with trees
[Music]
would you look at that I think we have
ourselves a finished painting so from
our family to yours keep your pants dry
your dreams oh gosh the Deadpool
marketing is the best oh that's so much
fun is that the best mask anyone I kind
of forgot the Deadpool marketing tends
to have so much random fun yeah a
meanness that's so opposite of what
we're used to they go against the grey
with their marketing the first ones I
forgot about what I was supposed to
expect and so yeah surprise all over I
thought I was just gonna see a trailer
[Applause]
guys might be like 10 seconds long
there's a whole lot spoof of Bob Ross
and the stuff he was saying was just so
freakin funny man this is something you
got to watch again because while he's
making jokes he also have to read the
funny lines of the painting everyone's
got guns in this trailer and negasonic
teenage warhead has hair you could
already tell just by the little like to
ten seconds of footage they they gave us
that there's a slight up in the
production quality oh yeah it seems like
all the favorite characters that we love
are returning and there's some new faces
in there as well
even Deadpool's roommates back yeah you
get Domino in there as well a new
character he says she's from Atlanta
right oh yeah yeah and then you also
have that one shot of I don't know that
character but the dude who's like it
looks like he's saying some fire I don't
know if he's in if he was able to do
that with some type of superpower but
this film looks like it's gonna be a
little bit bigger a little crazier but
the type of marketing that are doing
assures you that he'll still be just as
wacky and silly maybe even more he's
popping out of the coffin at one point I
like a funeral yeah
excited to see what david leitch is
gonna do this cuz it seems like he
really brought some of that John wick
bravado oh yeah a lot of good because in
the first set of pool they had to cut
back on some gun action for budgeting
purposes okay and it's a lot more sword
action here you're like wow there's a
lot of guns just like we'd want from
david leitch excited to see what he does
swords to and all that absolutely but at
the end you don't actually see a face of
cable but you do see that's yeah you get
cables hand in there which is this is a
really good tin this is like the best
kind of Deadpool to you to teaser
trailer you can possibly get yeah booth
one that played before Logan and this
one yeah this is the best marketing you
could do for Deadpool - hey man props to
them cuz they they make me effortlessly
excited absolutely
well hey shout out to add your Terpening
today our patron of the day herp a derp
derpity was actually just in california
recently and he went and watched daddy's
home - with us we cuddled with him while
Mark Wahlberg and Will Ferrell tore up
the Cineplex and speaking of guns he is
a military man so he legally owns a
firearm he does and he agreed to show me
it I held a gun I think for the first
time in my life
cocked it and everything I was the most
badass person and the world was crazy no
bullets in the chamber hundred percent
safe bad but it made me go and you're
chirping he's good with guns this guy
right here he is tall he is good-looking
he is a military man he could be in the
next Deadpool movie and that's what I
want for you Andrew yeah man Deadpool 3
starring Andrew Turpin I just don't talk
to my girlfriend again just don't do
that when you guys were bonding hear
what you'd comment so please don't do
that again
please don't doctor you are better than
me subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell you can follow us
on social media from a picture on eject
today pour everything over at patreon it
helps keep this channel running and
there's some awesome reward tiers over
there as well